launching a drone in Nepal's chitwan
national park the 1000 square kilometer
area is home to rare species like Bengal
tigers and rhinos both are at risk of
extinction due to hunting by poachers
Rangers are using the unmanned devices
to patrol the area from the air with the
help of the unmanned aerial vehicle we
were able to identify suspicious
activity enables us to take immediate
action the drone is fitted with a camera
which can record videos as well as take
snapshots the World Wide Fund for Nature
began using the devices in Nepal two
years ago the Rangers can control them
from a distance of 25 kilometers the
technology is supposed to act as a
deterrent
always the criminals are limited ahead
then the enforcement so we need to
tackle those criminals in time so we we
should not rely on the like analytic
method that a patrolling and you know
like a informant mobilizes which also we
also need to like use modern technology
and equipment so that it will be it will
effect as a deterrent factor back at the
base the Rangers can begin to analyze
the material shot by the drone after
flying the drone over the protected area
we retrieve the chip out of the camera
and download the photos and video on to
a computer then we scour the footage for
any abnormal activity if any action
needs to be taken we immediately send
out a team the technology is proving
successful in the last four years the
tiger population has risen from 121 to
almost 200 a rise of over 60% shift says
go wild